in Boston's industrial north end there
is a small easy to miss historical
plaque it marks one of the strangest
disasters in history on a January
afternoon in 1919 patrolman Frank
McManus found himself shouting into his
transmitter he could barely believe what
he was saying
send all rescue vehicles and personnel
immediately there's a wave of molasses
coming down commercial street the purity
distilling company was in the molasses
business but they weren't in it to make
syrup or sweets they were in it to make
booze and bombs and they were in a rush
they have filled up their largest tank
with as much molasses as they could find
because they were racing against
prohibition they needed to get this
stuff turned into liquor and sold before
it was illegal the tank that this
molasses was stored in was huge it was
the size of a building and contained 2.3
million gallons of molasses and when it
burst a two-story tall wave of molasses
went flying out in all directions and it
was traveling at 35 miles per hour and
it wasn't just the sugary tide that was
deadly the tank itself became a weapon
huge pieces of metal went flying into
buildings and the rivets that had held
the tank together shot out like bullets
as the wave of molasses and the debris
it carried went down commercial street
it picked up entire buildings by their
foundations and just floated them out
towards the harbor molasses came pouring
in through people's windows and if you
were living for example in a basement
apartment you were in a lot of trouble
to give you an example of the power of
this disaster a steel beam that held up
the elevated train was destroyed
obliterated and the train tracks fell to
the ground and it was only by luck that
it missed taking out a train with it
molasses covered everything and as you
struggled it pulled you into it
according to the Boston Post horses died
like so many flies on Stiggy flypaper
it wasn't just horses that died the
Boston molasses flood killed
21 people author Steven poleo
wrote the best book about this called
dark tide described it thusly molasses
covered the street waist-deep and
swirled and bubbled about the wreckage
only an upheaval a thrashing about in
the sticky mass showed where any life
was and this illustrates really how
nightmarish this was the disaster caused
a hundred million dollars worth of
damage in today's money all done by a
wave of molasses this was the company's
fault
they were grossly negligent and they
knew there was a problem the tank was
built with the wrong metal it was built
to half the thickness it should have
been the night watchmen complained that
it creaked and groaned at night under
the stress and so much molasses was
leaking from the sides that they painted
it brown so you wouldn't notice after
one of the longest trials in US history
the company was finally found guilty and
paid a million dollar settlement it took
weeks and weeks to clean up the molasses
left after this disaster and the
neighborhood was said to be sticky to
the touch for years when the molasses
flood took 21 lives and destroyed a
neighborhood you'd never know it today
the only thing that marks it is a tiny
little sign but to this day if you talk
to a local resident they will swear and
on a hot summer's afternoon you can
smell the sweet aroma of molasses if you
want to learn more about this I cannot
recommend dark tide highly enough it's
wonderful it goes into a lot of
historical context and it goes deep into
this incredibly elaborate complicated
trial it's a really wonderful book so I
think the Boston molasses flood is the
strangest disaster to ever happen but if
you know of other disasters that you
think are on a similar kind of scale of
strangeness I would be really interested
to hear about them